well it's a great play
before you again and I want to
again for your interest in my work and
for taking the time to come and hear my
thoughts the the the previous lecture
was called moral sentiments and material
interests and I guess a good number of
you were here for that lecture some of
you weren't I'll say one or two things
about it the lecture today is outlined
there and there'll be a third lecture on
next Monday which with some liberties I
took with Russo who said something
somewhat similar to the title of the
last lecture but not quite the same now
let me say a couple of things about what
I did last time because there are some
faces here that I didn't see before I
began citing Machiavelli from the
discourses he said that in designing a
republic the the person who wants to
order the laws in such a republic must
assume that all men are wicked hunger
and poverty make them industrious and
laws make them good and he didn't mean
that laws make them into good people he
meant that laws make them act as if they
were good that's him this is of course
quite different from Aristotle who
thought that the job of the legislature
is to produce good citizens among other
things in fact he said it's the main
criterion of a good convention I I
introduced Hume who told the legislature
or Constitution writer that he ought to
suppose in designing a constitution that
all people are knaves and to find a way
to harness the knavery of individuals
towards the public good there by
executing a kind of alchemy turning
shabby motives into valued social
objectives and I then also explain how
of course Adam Smith and economists
generally have developed this idea much
further the problem that I introduced
was what is what I called crowding out
or crowding in I there was an assumption
called separuh bility in which the idea
is that was assumed by Bentham and
and Smith implicitly by human others and
that is that one could mobilize the
material interest through incentives and
taxes and so on without harming the
Moral Sentiments to do a good job as a
citizen in any case the idea that these
two things might be somehow connected in
this way the incentives inducing the
correct action but also affecting the
values positively or negatively and
having an effect on the action that way
of course crowding out is when that
effect on values is negative and
crowding in is when it's positive I
presented lots of evidence to the effect
that that was true I mentioned the
Boston firemen calling in sick when the
incentives for them not to call in sick
were cranked up and their pay was docked
if they were sick and they called in
sick it had in record numbers the eye
closed last time with a passage from
Burke who told us in the reflections on
the French Revolution the age of
chivalry is gone that of safa stirs
economists and calculators has succeeded
and that's what I want to talk about
today the dire consequences of this new
era oh I also I also introduced many
experiments I won't even say with that
one is because I'm sure you all remember
now because the titles Machiavelli's
mistake and people always ask me what's
the mistake it's this that there exists
some set of material incentives I you
know taxes market prices subsidies and
so on which can implement a socially
desirable outcome irrespective of
individual preferences that's the idea
of course I don't attribute that
particular idea to Machiavelli but
rather he was one who shifted the
attention of thinkers about politics
away from producing ideal citizens and
towards the idea of taking citizens as
they are as Machiavelli said those with
the natural humors of ordinary citizens
now the advantage of this position is of
course that it allows you to dispense
almost entirely with virtue as a problem
and all
so then avoids the embarrassment of
having to make the creation of virtue a
part of public policy which is of course
deeply troublesome to most liberals it's
mistaken I said at the beginning of the
last lecture and I'll I'll complete this
on Monday it's it's mistaken because
virtue is not dispensable it's
indispensable the reason for that is
that many contracts are incomplete and
therefore there is no way that you and
contracts are incomplete and the
subsidies and taxes and so on that are
designed to correct that are necessarily
limited in a liberal society I'll
explain on Monday why they're so limited
by liberalism itself and it's a good
thing that they are I would say and as I
say the problem is that the incentives
may actually have an effect on
diminishing the virtues there by
intensifying the problem now the I want
to ask here is is Mandeville's mistake
mistaken for a third reason when I
haven't considered yet and that's that
liberal society actually destroys itself
the use of incentives and so on actually
is a non reproducible policy so here's
the idea that here's the parasite
hypothesis I'm going to define liberal
society by societies which make
extensive use of markets equality of
political rights rule of law public
tolerance much attenuated descriptive
barriers to mobility and I'll say this
just in contrast to other societies
which I'll call traditional or non
liberal and you'll see by my reference
to particular societies which I have in
mind I don't have any particular I mean
of course we could define these things
somewhat differently all I need is a
group of countries here in a group of
countries that are not liberal in that
sense the parasite hypothesis says that
liberal societies depend on a substrate
of virtues I name some of them there was
reciprocity altruism and so on these are
perpetuated by traditions families other
traditional institutions which are
jeopardized by the liberal institutions
themselves so essentially the lib
the mobility tolerance markets and so on
destroy the traditional institutions on
which the virtues are depend those
virtues being necessary for the
functioning of liberal institutions
including the polity markets and so on
so that's the hypothesis now you might
ask well look economists have said
forever that markets economize on
virtues so do why would we care suppose
the use of market totally obliterated
virtues is that really a problem now if
I'm just asking you to think abstractly
here because many us would take it to be
a problem for some other reasons than
the functioning of markets and so on but
let's look at what how this reasoning
goes here's Hayek says that a market
system is one in which bad men can do
very little harm or here's a Buchanan
another Nobel Prize winner in economics
describing purchasing fruit at a fruit
stand near blacksburg virginia where he
lives I don't know the fruit salesman
personally I have known a particular
interest in his well-being he
reciprocates this attitude I don't know
and I have no need to know whether he's
in the diarist of poverty extremely
wealthy or somewhere in between yet the
two of us are able to transact exchanges
efficiently because both parties agree
on the property rights relevant to them
so here's an idea of an individual who
is absolutely indifferent towards his
fellow citizens but somehow things were
pretty well anyway as long as this
assumption of complete property rights
is given now I said in the last lecture
of course that's a big assumption that's
a big problem now so this idea of
eliminating virtue and just by cranking
up the incentives runs into two
objections you can never economize so
much on virtue that you can get with get
along without it in some cases the
methods which would be used to economize
on virtually the incentives actually
destroy the virtue so that the
incentives backfire and in some cases
the market like arrangements may just
compromise these these virtues in such a
way that the society becomes unstable
that instability idea is the parasite
hypothesis the previous one was about
you know incentives backfiring but I
want to look now at a long historical
period and say well what would be the
long trajectory of a society constituted
by these institutions which I call
liberal but depending on the values
which I've referred to now as I say many
people have said such a thing they're as
varied as Burke the talk vil marx and
engels I'm I won't read these quotes to
you I'm sure you know them all but
they're basically saying similar
problems Daniel bells cultural
contradictions of capitalism the famous
book 30 years ago the historic
justification of bourgeois society in
the realms of religion and character are
gone the lack of a rooted moral belief
system is the cultural contradictions of
this society and by the way if because I
was myself trained in the major that Ian
referred to it was then called politics
political and economic institutions I of
course read all these guys as an
undergraduate including schumpeter
palani and all these other people and in
various passages they say very similar
things I won't bore you with that now
remember I'm not promoting this
hypothesis or at least not yet I'm
investigating it so you'll have to bear
with me what I'm going to do is I'm
going to suggest that there's some
evidence that it might be true well then
I'll propose a model in which it is true
and then we'll ask should we believe
this so let's start with some evidence
for it we're going to go to Ghana these
are workers in Accra where we've done
experiments of the following kinds the
dictator game you'll remember is a game
in which an individual is a sign
provisionally sum sum of money which he
or she may give to the other individual
the respondent that's the end of the
game nothing else happens it's just
interesting to see how much people give
now there's an interesting variant on
that which is called the third party
punishment game which is there there's
the dictator as before there is the
passive respondent as before but now
there's a third party who is an onlooker
and the onlooker knows how much the
dictator got no
how much he or she gave to the other
person and can if she wishes take some
money out of her pocket and pay to
punish the dictator for being
insufficiently generous to the
respondent you get the idea so that's
that the respondent doesn't do anything
ever it's just the the the third party
can impose a cost if if the offer is
thought to be unfair now the interesting
thing here is that in the dictator game
there are no incentives you just do what
you do in the third party game of course
there are because you're likely to be
fined if you don't give enough so you
have to look at that situation say well
jeez how much can I get away with and
how much will it find B and so on in
Ghana the people there these are bakers
and men sewing pinafores little dress
addresses for kids they gave thirty
percent more in the dictator game than
they gave in the third party punishment
game okay you get why that's a surprise
they should have given more in the third
party punishment game because in the
third party punishment game whatever
motive they had for giving to the other
person would now be supplemented
additively presumably if the separable
ax t assumption is correct would have
been supplemented by the inducement
which is provided by the fine now if
that's all we found out I wouldn't be
wouldn't be reporting this here but what
we found out in the dictator game is
something really quite interesting which
is that attendance at church or in a
mosque predicted offers that is the
people who were more quote religious in
that sense gave more the economic
circumstances of the individuals
mattered not at all they were
statistically insignificant in their
coefficients were very small now in the
third party punishment game with the
addition of incentives the reverse was
true the religious variables had no
interest in no explanatory power at all
they were insignificant and they were
tiny in size and all of a sudden the
economic circumstances of the wrists of
the respondent became important how much
income they had how many kids they had
and so on well what would you what do
you think about this one possible
interpretation certainly came to my mind
right away
is that the presence of the incentives
had somehow changed the way of thinking
about the problem from one in which
one's religious values were salient if
one was religious and that induced you
to give more the one in which religious
values were no longer saline but whether
you needed the money became salient or
you know something about your economic
circumstances this is precisely the kind
of experimental result which you would
expect to find if the parasite
hypothesis were true well let's see what
it would mean if it were true this is a
model of the hypothesis it consists of
exactly two equations two lines I
promise you there will be no more than
two but I ask you to pay attention to
how they work because I think we got a
rather interesting result by following
this so we have this is a problem which
I think you understand is one of the
hardest problems in the Social and
Behavioral Sciences and in history which
is how do we explain the joint evolution
of individual preferences and social
institutions that is things at the group
level and things at the individual level
in a some kind of dynamic involving both
moving over time they obviously
influenced each other and these two
equations you won't be surprised to know
that one reflects the interest of the
influence of the institutions on the
people and the other reflects the the
influence of the people on the
institutions so I'm going to just look
at the aggregate relations that come out
of the model I'm not going to start with
the individual choices and so on this
may be an asymptote of some of you in
economics but I don't think that it's
always insightful to start with the
individuals and build up these aggregate
relations I've done that this but i will
show you just the aggregate equilibrium
relationships so virtue on the given
that virtuous n czyli khanna Mieses
markets economize on virtue then it's
the case that virtue expands the domain
of mutually beneficial exchanges that is
sorry i say that wrong the more virtue
there is the more you can have mutually
beneficial exchanges because you don't
have to have complete contracts a
handshake will do or maybe eye contact
so lots of stuff that you couldn't
transact without the eye contact or
without the handshake will happen now I
show that here
here's virtue by the way anybody who
complains that virtues multi-dimensional
you have to be ready to go with me into
three-dimensional graphs or five or ten
right so let's just not even have that
conversation I'm saying suppose there
were a single dimension and I can assure
you that if I included ten dimensions of
virtue and to the two or three
dimensions of markets we would get the
same qualitative results so here we have
the extent of markets what fraction of
all of the things that are moved around
the society how is the division of labor
coordinated what role does the de
markets have in that those of you who
are economists will know the problem was
posed by ko's in the 30s when he said
defer beside to produce something or to
purchase it well that the boundary of
the firm is an example of the boundary
of a market here we have more market
more market role as market role and more
of these virtues and what this says this
function here says the level of market
use in a society will be greater in a
society the less the less there is
virtue and the idea is this markets have
a comparative advantage in working with
people of as makaveli said normal and
ordinary humours so if that's what we
have you better have markets as opposed
to other things like gift exchange or
some other kind of procedure for
coordinating the division of labor this
expression here just says that the slope
of this thing is negative the more
virtue you have in the society the more
will the members of that society like
the firms in kouzes argument or like any
individuals deciding on whether or not
to expand the scope of the market or not
it will it will be such that we have
this downward slope now what are these
things here that is an isoquant that
gives you the level of income or net
surplus in the society associated with
each of these any point on this these
are ISO quants meaning every point on
that top little dish shaped thing has
the same level of income this one is
higher than that one in income because
the virtues contribute to being able to
make transactions work which wouldn't be
possible in their absence quoting
Kenneth arrow from the previous lecture
now notice what I've done I've done
something a little fancy
here this is a locus of points that line
is a locus of points in which the aiesec
wants our flat well what that means is
suppose you have that much virtue in
this society right there well then how
much markets should you have well that
number there is what maximizes your
income I've just chosen a particular em
function it happens to be one that
maximizes the income of society I'm not
saying that because I believe that's the
way things work that's the way you know
for example Ronald pose would say in the
ideal circumstances that's the way our
institutions would evolve so as to
maximize in that manner I do this
because I'll come back to it later
perhaps next lecture and make use of
that particular construction here but
it's that's not it isn't necessary that
we have this income maximizing aspect
here it's rather frosting on the cake
for now now the markets crowd out virtue
that's the new line I put up there what
that says is the more markets you have
in equilibrium in a cultural equilibrium
in which people are adopting preferences
and learning from each other and so on
the less virtue you will have that's the
second part of the parasite hypothesis
so this line here says pick some level
of markets well then that's the level of
virtues that you'll have spread in the
population when people are engaging in
exchanges some part of the time they're
engaging with their family members or
with the state or with their residents
in nan market relations the rest of the
time its downward sloping and there are
two parts of this its downward sloping
in markets but look here we have this
semi colon and then tau tradition is
represented by tau tau sustains these
virtues its eroded by markets but for
the time being I'm going to say hold tau
constant it's just some number it's just
some amount of tradition we're looking
at a particular moment of history a
snapshot if you will will will bring in
the effect of the traditions changing in
just a minute well now every point on
this steep curve is in equilibrium in
the choice of the extension of market
every point on this locus here is an
equilibrium in people's updating of
their cultures whether by cultural
learning or maybe even genetic or any
other means by which we acquire our
tastes and our values a joint
intersection of these two functions is a
stationary point in the society in other
words that point there a is a set an
extent of markets and a level of values
that is self-reproducing and it's
self-reproducing because every point on
this line says that the degree of
markets is stationary and every point on
that line says a degree a virtue is
stationary and obviously if both are
stationary you have a what is called
cultural institutional equilibrium now
by the way none of the authors I wrote
about i mentioned had this in mind but i
thought to formalize what they were
going to say it would make sense to do
that let me ask you are there questions
about how this thing works the whole
idea of stationarity and equilibrium on
things like culture institutions maybe
something a little new I mean when you
look at something like that you either
think maybe it's a religious symbol or
it's a supply and demand curve and
you're talking about you know
stationarity of prices and quantities
but there's nothing wrong with applying
this to things like cultures and
institutions would somebody please ask
me an uninformed question and please
don't start by saying this may be very
dumb okay oh all right well I'll go on I
but do ask mean if you don't understand
how this works I really think I can
explain it to you and it's not rocket
science okay so here's the here's the
parasite model in action the overtime
markets erode tradition tradition
remember sustains the virtues and so the
virtue function shifts downwards that's
what's shown by these lines here so this
society here which has some degree of
markets over time through the erosion of
the tradition will have lower and lower
virtue lines that will shift the society
had to necessarily relying on markets to
a larger extent
because virtue is being undermined and
by the way this kind of equilibrium with
something which is held constant sort of
hypothetically is called a temporary
equilibrium it's kind of a low-budget
way of explaining what is in fact a much
more complex dynamical process
graphically yeah Chris okay okay the the
line itself here says with a given
amount of importance of churches and
extended families in the society with
that with that demographic and
institutional aspect not I'm not
changing if you increase the scope of
markets people will without abandoning
their religion or their family values
will become more self interested this
shifting down is a longer run thing
that's the only difference is a period
of time over which it takes place but
eventually destroyed the churches and
the families too and then you're in an
even worse situation because those were
sort of putting a break on the extent to
which markets encourage self-interest
yeah
it would but I don't think that it would
illuminate one way or the other pro or
con the parasite hypothesis although
actually I tell you the truth I'm going
to come back to exactly your point about
scope when I when I deal with Adam Smith
so I think my answer may have been
incorrect I think that I don't know
exactly how to modify this with respect
to scale but you'll see exactly where
it's going to come up later and probably
you'll have an idea then about how to do
it okay well here's a funny picture but
there's nothing wrong with with it I
suppose the functions look like this
well how can they look like that why not
all I've showed you is that they're both
downward sloping if they're both
downward sloping it's accidental ethics
if they intersect only once they can
intersect any number of times they want
now these two functions are the same
here we have the values function and
that's the market function up here we
have an equilibrium in which we have a
very virtuous society with very little
markets and down here we have the
opposite I don't expect all of you to
into it what about the middle one but
the middle one is unstable if you take
out a piece of paper and you're right
down the arrow is about where it's going
to go from every point in this space
it's called a vector field and this is a
state space of a dynamical system that
equilibrium there is a saddle point and
you will you will be pushed away from
that by any small perturbation so the
society could be here or it could be
there now let's bring in to effect the
historical or long-term effects of
tradition on the society that as the
tradition decays first remove say we're
suppose we start there we move from that
then we move down a little bit and you
see what happens if you keep moving that
function downward eventually you destroy
the upper intersection it disappears so
at a certain point you get down to about
there and then you go precipitously all
the way down to be
sorry the lower equilibrium that's the
collapse part of the parasite hypothesis
that's how you could have a long-term
stasis of liberal democratic capitalist
and let's say followed by a radical
collapse operating over period a period
of a generation or even less so in other
words i think the thesis can be written
down in ways that are perfectly coherent
and i can provide you with data which
would suggest that some of these things
are probably true so should we take it
seriously should we follow burke talk
ville daniel bell and others well
surprise surprisingly i actually did
some evidence some experiments that
produce quite a surprise for me these
are haads of hunters with whom i
actually hunted in tanzania and we
played the ultimatum game almost all of
you know it so i'll run quickly through
this their two subjects one is the
proposer he or she's given sum sum of
money offers it to the other person some
part of it any part from zero to the
whole thing the third the respondent can
accept or reject if the responder
accepts that's the end of the game if
the responder rejects that's also the
end of the game but both parties get
zero and I think you should probably
share my interpretation that if you find
people accepting offers of say twenty
bucks when the person had a hundred to
give it's probably because they're
pretty irritated that they didn't get a
fair share and that's a common
interpretation of the game now a group
of us did experiments in 15 small-scale
societies including hunter-gatherers and
pastoral societies agricultural
horticultural small-scale agriculture
and so on the places that we did these
experiments are all there but you notice
there's Detroit and LA and Zurich are
those are not small-scale societies
that's where we pre tested this we
pre-tested the thing well here's a funny
picture this is the offers in the
ultimatum game
normalized obviously is how generous the
respondent was this is a measure of the
degree of market involvement of the
societies in which we did the tests I'm
happy to explain to you how we got those
measures I think they're probably pretty
good these are ordinal measures however
so there you know you could you could
have a rather different picture of this
if you but it it'd be almost impossible
that you didn't have a positive
relationship the more market eyes
societies are the more generous and by
the way in case you're curious in the
more market eyes societies people
rejected unfair offers much more
frequently so it looks like the market
is doing the opposite of what the
parasite hypothesis is saying but I'd
like to point out here these are
extremely low levels of market
involvement these are these are people
who literally I mean they buy and sell
things hardly ever except for well the
lamb elara these are whale hunters they
actually sell some of their meat and so
on but it's basically these are way
outside markets now let's try a better
test public goods game you remember the
public goods game it's an N person
prisoner's dilemma and you play the game
anonymously you can contribute to the
pot whatever is in the pot or you can
keep your money yourself whatever is in
the pot after it's gone around is
doubled or tripled by the experimenter
and divided equally among all parties
the dominant strategy in the game
meaning the strategy that a selfish
individual would would undertake
irrespective of what anybody else does
is you don't contribute any well here we
have these are German subjects and they
start out by contributing a little more
than six and these are rounds and they
end up contributing very little at the
end but they do try to they they give it
a try at the beginning this is it this
is a stranger treatment in each period
their their group is eliminated and they
start with another so in period one
there's one group playing in period two
it's that you're playing in a different
group so there's no motive for
behavior modification here at the end of
period 10 the experimenters fair and get
or say okay we're going to play by
different rules now at the end of each
round you're going to see who
contributed what and you can take some
money out of your pocket and you can
find them of course the word fine would
never be used but you can deduct their
payoffs well we start their notice they
they start a little higher not much
higher the prospect that there's
punishment out there can be a problem
and it you got a dramatic increase here
in the contributions now as I said
there's a nice puzzle here which is
people are very generous when it comes
to punishing they can sustain punishing
and in a group but they can't sustain
the cooperation but when punishing is
possible then they generously punish
they solve the public goods game of
punishing when they couldn't solve the
public goods game of contributing I'll
come back to that in my last lecture
because I think we can extract from that
some wisdom for how a policymaker ought
to think about economic policy well this
game was played in 15 different 15 by
the way for some reason all these things
come in 15 played in these societies
around the world these are all student
populations and their none of them
small-scale societies and this is the
same picture I just gave you of the
first part of the game you see the
declining contributions and then here's
when you add the punishment you sustain
the cooperation so in every single one
of those societies you you replicate
what you find in the single ones which
is it unravels without punishment it's
sustained if you have punishment people
punish rather avidly in these games now
that sounds great so far except that
there's what's called antisocial
punishment in most subject pools when
you limit the time frame to just the
period that we have 10 periods the
treatments in which they're not allowed
to punish they actually end up with
higher payoffs than the ones in which
they are allowed to pay offs in other
words having the cooperation decline
is not as bad for payoffs as it is
having everybody punishing everybody
because that's very expensive it has a
lot of counter punishment and so on what
they call antisocial punishment and so
here we have the author's call this
antisocial punishment on the left-hand
side you're punishing people who
contributed less than you on the right
hand side you're punishing people who
contribute it the same amount as you or
more take a look at Athens or yeah look
at Athens hey as much as much of the
punishing with people who did the same
as you or more interpret an
interpretation of this is that suppose I
got punished and then what do I infer
while I infer was one of those
goody-goodies who is contributing a lot
of punishment this was a partner
treatment this is not a stranger
treatment so what do I do next period i
punish that guy I find out who you know
and it happens very avidly but there's
an interesting pattern here the the ones
that really these these ones here who
really learned how to make it work
properly here we have the payoffs
relative to what happened when
punishment wasn't allowed so these ones
here learned how to do it by the end of
the game they were doing great these
ones here didn't and what's the
difference well it turns out that Boston
Copenhagen Melbourne Nottingham st.
gallen gin do sol and Zurich are the top
performers in figuring out how to do
this and the other ones didn't work out
well except for Chen do it's a China
soul it's pretty obvious what that list
is basically it's you I don't know what
you want to call it but i would call
those liberal societies with the two
exceptions that i mentioned let me say
more about my interpretation of that
those who didn't work it out got in got
engaged in these vendetta's these arms
races which now the the public goods
with punishment that's a PG WP game the
highest average contributions were the
ones here and the lowest are the ones
you can see Athens Riyadh Muscat
and so on oh this happened last time and
not some people thought some people
thought I should learn my lesson but I
did I just unplugged what I now know is
called a dongle I didn't know I had one
but now we do it by hand I suppose we
could do it a little more efficiently
this way I know those of you who are
your last time know that it last time it
took us how long seven minutes to do
this the average contribution levels in
the game with punishment correlated very
highly with measures of such things as
you would consider to be part of a
liberal society like rule of law
democracy individualism and social
equality social equality is roughly
whether you call your boss by the first
name I mean I'm just kidding a little
bit but there's a there is an
international measure of interpersonal
relationships of equality in symbolic
things like how you address them and so
on so you can see basically the ones who
are really doing this thing are the
liberal societies the ones who are
succeeding in this game which i think is
a pretty good prototype of a game of
citizenship contributing and also
upholding the norms of the public
antisocial punishment is likewise
extraordinarily positively correlated
and negatively correlated with these
measures of what I call liberal society
so what does this tell us it seems to be
leaning pretty heavily against the
parasite hypothesis because the basic
idea the parasite hypothesis seems to be
disproved the liberal society seemed to
be doing quite a bit better by this
measure of civic virtue and by the way I
don't mean this is the only measure one
could use but I would be happy for
anybody to propose any measure that you
will defend and find a different result
I haven't found one yet well this this
idea then suggests that you know maybe
Montesquieu and Smith were right ah that
exchange market exchange / do
these benign effects on human behavior
and human morals by this mechanism which
is referred to by as Dooku Maris because
it was montesquieu who first said that
the Commerce sweetens or softens manners
so here's Voltaire are wonderful
exponent of this view enter the exchange
of London that place more respectable
than many a cork you will see their
agents from all nations assembled for
the utility of mankind the Jew the
[ __ ] the Christian deal with one
another as if they were of the same
religion and they give the name infidel
only to those who go bankrupt or here's
montesquieu a slightly more reasoned
account it's almost a general rule that
wherever the ways of men are gentle
there's commerce and wherever there's
commerce the ways are gentle commerce
polishes and softens that's where the
Odyssey comes from barbarian ways and so
on now of course reading these guys I
was struck by how none of them said how
this happens I mean it does montes uses
it to correlation and so I looked until
I found as you know the lectures on
jurisprudence were note taken by his
students by Adam Smith here's his
explanation and it if those of you who
said had repeated games will understand
this is exactly what has now been
modeled in repeated game theory when a
person makes perhaps 20 contracts in a
day he cannot gain so much by
endeavoring to impose on his neighbors
as the very appearance of a cheat would
make him lose when people seldom deal
with one another we find that they are
somewhat disposed to cheat because they
can gain more by a smart trick and they
can lose by the injury which it does to
their character that's that's a pretty
decent argument I'll consider it shortly
he did say that ambassadors were likely
to be a little shady and to cut corners
and I decided to look into that so I i
took a measure i found out the number of
unpaid parking tickets of the diplomats
at the united nations
and so but deadbeat diplomats was Smith
right about the diplomat see well he
certainly was you would be astounded by
the average number of unpaid parking
tickets there is one delegation at the
United Nations that averages 147 unpaid
parking tickets per diplomat now I mean
you really have to work at that I've
used it man leave the car in the middle
of the street every time you get out of
it I won't say which that is it's not
one of my cherished liberal countries
but I did decide to just for fun measure
the parking tickets against various
measures of liberalism if you will this
one here is these are the top 25 rule of
law and these are the remaining 100 or
so in rule of law this is the top 25 in
terms of a measure of democracy and so
on there's vast differences I mean now
you may ask well maybe it has to do with
anti-american sentiment maybe the cost
of paying a ticket is greater the other
countries and so on you could play
around with the data but you're never
going to make it go backwards you're
never going to make it come out right
for the parasite hypothesis now Smith
Smith rightly said in that passage about
repeated interactions that markets are a
kind of school their place where we
learn things where we adopt certain
character traits and abide by them he
was saying we do it for reasons of
self-interest but they lead us to act in
in in ways which we refer to as virtues
now this is of course a big topic but i
think i would like you to entertain the
idea that an economic environment like a
market or a firm is a cultural
environment it's a learning environment
it's a it's a learning environment
because basically it's it determines who
you meet with what probability to do
what what are these what's your strategy
sets or what your activities that you do
with which kind of payoffs so if you're
the kind of person that's copying others
according to whether or not they're
doing well in terms of their payoffs a
difference in the environment will alter
your updating process leading you to
copy one kind of person as opposed to
know
depending on the payoff to these various
activities which of course are
strategically dependent on what
everybody else does now markets Smith is
right markets provide an environment in
which if you have long-term repeated
interactions they may have that
characteristic of allowing people or in
giving people a benefit of acting in a
moral way towards others because the
consequences of retaliation would be
sufficiently great but it's hard to say
that markets would do this more than
other institutions which is of course
the important fact here I have two
characteristics of institutions there
either ephemeral or they're durable
they're either anonymous or their
personal so I was trying to ask myself
what our markets really like ah and what
well I think what markets are like
psychologically is that they're
anonymous and ephemeral now I don't mean
they're literally anonymous and
ephemeral I may know the name of the guy
who i buy gasoline from but I don't need
to and I may go back to him again and
again but I don't need to it would make
no difference in the analysis of the gas
market whether I knew his name or went
to a different guy every day so this is
these are what I call markets and these
other things are other ways of
organizing an economy parts of an
economy now this the way I've described
a market here that's a kind of
neoclassical market it's an ideal type
Smith was talking about markets which
were presumably operating at a rather
small scale and which people didn't
interact with very many people however
as markets expand you interact with
thousands of people as mobility expands
you probably don't know or don't have
that much interest in knowing very much
about some of the people you interact
with or as economists advise
policymakers to try to quote perfect
markets what they're doing is they're
making Marcus into institutions which
have no resemblance whatsoever to the
market which were described by Adam
Smith as having this Duke amaris effect
namely markets in which people interact
for a very long period of time you want
an example what is it what is this
mantra now fly
ssible labor markets a flexible labor
market is a market in which the average
worker has a lesser duration of time
likely to work with a group of work
mates and with a particular employer
because it's much easier to fire him now
flexible labor markets would destroy
Smith's Smith's mechanism now I would if
I if I had time I would give you some
examples of that because I think Smith
is absolutely right that some market
some contracts have been enforced by
that kind of mechanism and they tend to
be destroyed by the expanding scope of
markets thank you for that question I
can give you a couple from European
economic history you'll see one is the
famous case of the maghrib e versus the
Genovese a traders another is the
so-called community responsibility
system for contractual enforcement both
of which had this adam smith ian
characteristics but were obliterated by
the by the growth of markets the
extended markets now so what's my
explanation of this of these data well
order is maintained in not in
non-liberal societies an important part
by lineage based segments of the society
is by families and I mean something let
me just give you an example to convey
the idea if if somebody from Chris's
family had stolen one of my animals or I
believe so then I wouldn't think of and
suppose I suspect it's chris what I
would I try to punish Chris no way
somebody from my lineage would go to his
group and say we think Chris is acting
badly indeed we think he took one of
Sam's animals and so what are you going
to do about it and that's a very
important part of order what would
happen if I went personally to Chris and
beat him up or stole one of his animals
I would get all of his brothers and
cousins on my case because I would have
violated the norm which is I have no
right to maintain order in that lineage
the now by the way the story I made up I
don't really know that he took my dog
but I
but I'm drawing on a very rich
literature about the way in which order
is maintained in segments airy societies
now the role of families now have a
rather different sense than at the
beginning families are then a problem
for liberal culture they're not the
source of the values they're rather an
impediment because essentially if you
have if you rely heavily on family or on
the lineages these larger numbers common
descent then you're very much more
likely to have a for example a view of
reciprocity or trust which is very
particular it's you've trust people in
your lineage you don't trust anybody
else you'll reciprocate with people who
are in your lineage but not with others
and so on there's some wonderful work
done by Ernst Gellner the anthropologist
atocha yamagishi the social psychologist
Diego Gambetta the sociologist
developing the idea that what's
happening in the process of the
expansion of markets and expansion of
liberal societies is the destruction of
these particular istic forms of orders
and the substitution by a more general
form of order which we refer to as rule
of law and so on but i want to emphasize
something particular about this liberal
society does a great job of Risk
Reduction now that may seem odd to you
because it seems like something in which
you know you're kind of on your own but
the downside the worst thing that can
happen to you is often quite attenuated
by various things that are part of that
society but one thing is the rule of law
basically it means you know having a
bodily harm done to you and having a
property stolen and so on it's less
likely that in most other societies
liberal societies are relatively
peaceful but focus on mobility if you're
in a part of the country that's growing
a crop that fails in the world market
let's say if you're in a liberal society
you can easily move someplace else
you're quite mobile you're not in a cast
of people who has to make shoes you can
shift to making something else so you're
not labeled
by an occupation or a crop or and so on
so the geographical and social mobility
allows people to move away from their
their worst case outcomes of course very
recently we have social insurance but I
think that's probably much less
important in the larger scale of things
than the fact that of the tremendous
mobility of individuals occupationally
in geographically in a liberal society
and what that does is it makes these
family ties relatively unimportant and
what that does is it encourages
generosity and reciprocity towards
strangers and that's what i call the
civic virtues or it's a part of what i
call the civic virtues because to make a
large scale of modern society work we
don't need loyalty towards our cousins
we need loyalty towards people whose
names we don't know now i think i'm
going to set aside the crowding in what
I'm arguing here I would give you I'll
tell you this story but I won't give you
the model the idea is this liberal
society makes it okay to trust the other
guy why because the worst he can do to
you is not that great not that bad so
think of traffic suppose people at bay
traffic norms as long as almost
everybody else does but the suppose are
some just flagrant violators if those
people are effectively find and if you
know they're going to be fined even if
you see them cutting in and so on you
don't then start cutting in yourself if
you think they're going to get away with
it after a while you're just like one of
those people in the public goods game
without punishment you say well hell
they're not contributing I won't either
so this this this yamagishi shinato
paper is really a really clever it's a
public goods game in which the following
happens same public goods game except on
one of the treatments I I go to Bob but
only him and I say Bob everyone else in
your group is going to get punished if
they don't contribute enough to this as
far as you're concerned you can go ahead
what everyone no punishment for you okay
now we know how much he contributed
before and his incentives in this new
treatment are identical to his
incentives before he contributes much
more
knowing that everybody else is going to
be punished well what does that tell you
his material incentives hasn't change
its just that he doesn't worry about
being a sucker in the situation good he
knows that he doesn't have to withhold
his contribution to protect his non
sucker status he's going to be okay as
far as that's concerned now it's of
course what is this this says
essentially many liberal institutions
have the effect of crowding in virtue it
makes it makes it much more likely you
can trust the other guy because you're
less likely to be taken advantage of and
the little model here it's oh I'm sure
that you would love it but so let me
summarize what I think is going on in
these data the in early modern Europe
you have the rise of first absolutist
and much later democratic states
representative first and democratic
states and the rule of law I'll call
that Sigma I put that as a new argument
in these functions and I basically say
this that essentially by the argument I
just said the crowding in argument that
shifts up the virtue case makes it
possible to act in a trusting whale
under the under circumstances in which
you wouldn't have acted trusting in the
absence of that kind of society and
because of the defense of private
property definition and defensive
private property it allows the greater
extent of market it makes them more the
greater use of markets more efficient
and so therefore we see this symbiotic
development of powerful states and
market commercial societies they did not
develop an opposition I hope you know
that they developed synergistically and
you have a shift from at equilibrium to
that one there in which the more market
eyes societies are also more virtuous it
need not go that way play around with a
graph a little bit and you'll see that
you could have other kinds of
relationships it does suggest however
that if some societies are more
market-oriented than others we should
see differences in civic virtues in them
that is we should be able to test that I
can't think of exactly how to test that
not because I can't measure the virtues
you are you already understand but I'm
perfectly happy to measure those in all
kinds of odd way
but it's actually the hard thing is
measuring the extent of the market okay
so here's here's my conclusion the I'm
repeating in italics what the hypothesis
was liberal societies depend on the
substrate of virtue etc that's true
these values were pecha weighted by
tradition that's false liberal societies
jeopardize these traditional
institutions that's true and hence the
reproduction of the values on which the
functioning of liberal society depends
that's false the argument is that the
robust Civic Society or civil society of
the Liberals countries or nations the
things i mentioned kindness towards
stranger generalized as opposed to
particular reciprocity and so on maybe
indeed undermined by markets but it's
supported by the rule of law and what I
call liberal insurance and it's also
supported by the diminished role of
tradition and other non liberal
institutions so the answer to the
question is no that returns us then to
Machiavelli's mistake and what to do
about it so we now set aside a third
reason why Machiavelli might have been
mistaken and we now have to focus on the
first to this the first one says we
there's no way to make values
indispensable and the second one says
incentives may crowd them out so that if
values are necessary and applying higher
levels of incentives may have
destructive effects then the public
policy maker has a serious problem so
next time monday I'm going to introduce
you to an interesting fellow this is the
sophisticated legislature the
sophisticated legislature knows all of
this has taken it on board he believes
it and he's a very good mechanism
designer he knows implementation theory
for microeconomics and he's going to
design incentives with this problem in
mind now he has a lot harder problem
than Machiavelli's Prince or then Humes
a knave managing Constitution writer or
Bentham's legislator or mask and social
planner for that matter to mention
eric maskin the great mechanism designer
of one of the great mechanism design
guys have the present period the in
designing how you would approach this
knowing what i'm going to take on board
as if it were true these facts I think
you'll be surprised at some of the
results some of you may have read a book
by titmuss on blood paying for blood and
the gift relationship if you pay for
blood people don't give blood right I'm
sure you've read about that if you
haven't read the book i'm sure you've
read about it well of course he thought
that incentives he was basically that's
an indictment of incentives it's
actually quite a bit more interesting
than that and and i'll spare you that
model too so this is what happens next
and I think I've and I'd like to thank
again all the people that have
contributed I didn't say who all these
people are that's the Santa Fe Institute
that's the University of Siena that's a
group of my my research team at the
University of Siena and other people
visiting and this is justice on the Town
Hall wall in siena italy where i live
and work thank you very much